[Music]
[Applause]
all right hello welcome
as Erin mentioned I'm Nick and I see I'm
a JavaScript developer like many of you
and I work for a company called site
Penn they're sorry and we're hiring
I'm also on two podcasts j/s party and
talk script both of which are here yes
party just had the stage in the last
over lunch in the last in the other room
and come stop by either of those booths
I'll be over at the talks crit booth
throughout the day so please stop by and
we're interviewing speakers and
attendees so I am a dynamic language
enthusiast I'm a full-stack JavaScript
developer and this is how I would
describe myself I really like JavaScript
and I think I like it and I think I got
into it because it was a dynamic
language so I'd like to tell you a
little bit about my story and how I got
here
I graduated from college in 2008 and the
primary languages that were taught in my
computer science classes were C and C++
these were really nice languages I
learned a lot from them and learned I
think I became a better programmer I was
actually the last class that took C and
C++ they switched over to Java after
that I think I got the better education
so I'm happy about that
I also took an elective Perl class and
this is my first real introduction to a
dynamic language and I loved how
productive I could be quickly I didn't
have to worry about a make file which I
didn't understand at the time and I
didn't have to worry about all of this
setup and how I was gonna run and how
like freeing memory and all of that I
think that was the most freeing part I
could just start writing code run it and
if there was errors I'd get those thrown
at me and then I could deal with them so
that was my first real dynamic language
I did experiment once in college with
JavaScript but Perl was was the first
real one I just loved how flexible it
was so the the JavaScript that I wrote
in college was just for one
and it was just an add-on to a software
engineering project that I was working
on with a few other developers and this
was probably around 2007 and this is
what the code looked like it was
exceptionally terrible I think I should
get bonus points for how terrible it was
if you look in there there is a with
statement in there that's amazing and
what this code did was we wanted to add
a gmail style loading indicator like you
see in the top right corner Gmail used
to look like that in 2007 and we wanted
to add that to our page but we weren't
really doing any kind of xhr calls or
anything like that we were just had
serving PHP pages but we wanted to have
this fancy look and feel so I found in a
book some code that looked like this
that was making the Gmail loading
indicator happen and I wanted to make
that happen I didn't really understand
the code at all so I pretty much copied
it verbatim as you do and that ended up
with me in the page that I was
requesting making Ajax requests for the
page that I was on just so that I would
have an asynchronous request in there
that would take a little bit of time I
even had a math dot random on there so
that the URL was different each time and
then it would load the page and then
once that was actually loaded it would
remove the loading indicator so the
loading indicator didn't actually
signify a loading of anything other than
the page that you were already on so we
were just wasting time but it was a lot
of fun and I didn't touch that was good
for a few years after this but it got me
thinking it got me thinking do you
remember the first lines of JavaScript
that you might have written and so I
asked this on Twitter last week and I
got a few responses that came back and
most of them were pretty much the same
exact thing they were oh yeah I was just
changing the color of something or as I
was hovering over a link I wanted to
change the opacity of it and a few of
them were I wanted to modify the page
with jQuery specifically so jQuery and
JavaScript were synonymous back then in
a lot of ways and so this was really
most people's introduction to the
language through this dhtml style
modifying of the page and that's because
javascript is just not really the best
language we were using it the way that
it was designed it's not really it never
really was designed to be the
to be used the way that we use it today
and that's proven by this quote from
Brendan Eich where he's talking about
JavaScript being the glue language that
part-time developers and designers would
use to glue together the components that
the real programmers who were writing
Java would be writing and obviously
we've moved past that but in a lot of
ways this was how a lot of us got
started including me my first job was
writing Java I was working on a big java
application and it was also a portable
application so we were designing several
portlets that would go into the page and
it did have a lot of JavaScript on the
pages that were doing things like event
handling and some simple client-side
validation things like that but we
didn't really treat JavaScript like a
real language and so we didn't test
JavaScript we didn't architect it we
just kind of threw it in wherever we
wanted it and that meant that any
portlet that was going to use some
JavaScript method we would just use that
to pollute the global namespace with
whatever methods that it needed and that
ended up being where we'd have like a
click handler function that was
duplicated on in every single portlet
and it would just pollute the global
namespace with all of that so it was
really exceptionally terrible but that's
just what we ended up doing on this also
this application specifically only had
to work in ie6 it did not work in
Firefox and Chrome wasn't really a thing
back then it only worked in ie6 and
nothing else not a 7 or anything just
ie6
and it relied on some weird quirks mode
bugs to get the the drop down navigation
to work so if you tried to load it in
another browser it actually wouldn't
work at all and so I did a lot of Java
and a lot of JavaScript and but it was
just this simple JavaScript but then we
got the opportunity to create the first
real JavaScript component that we would
use in this application but of course I
didn't want to have to do this in ie6
because ie6 was just terrible so I
started looking at greasemonkey and
writing a script that would modify the
page in real time without actually
changing our source code so that it
would work in Firefox and we could
navigate through the pages and use
Firebug to actually do some testing
and so the first real component that I
created was a slide navigator so kind of
like a PowerPoint in the browser a
little bit but way way simpler and it
was all written in JavaScript we started
with prototype and then moved on to
jQuery and it was awesome but it was
terrible code but I really embraced that
spaghetti code that I was writing it was
a lot of fun to write not a lot of fun
to test or to debug later on of course
but I didn't know that at the time it's
just a lot of fun to to be a part of
that so there's this this quote from
Brendan Eich always bet on JavaScript
and this saying kind of accurately
depicts the past present and future of
the language since this is the language
of the web the language is kind of set
off at a disadvantage from the start I'm
sorry at an advantage from the start
over any other language because if you
were writing code in the browser it is
JavaScript so we're using this language
that was never really designed to to
have the role that it does but we can't
really get away from it so I saw this on
reddit last week and thought it was
really funny
the nice thing about this language
though is that because of its unique
position as the language of the web that
means that if you're working on an
application in another language like
Java or Ruby or dotnet or named anything
else if it's touching the web that
project probably has JavaScript in it
somewhere and that's a really cool thing
because that means that these
programmers that are programming in
other languages get to bring all of
their experiences and their design
decisions and their ideas over to this
language and try and influence it and so
Java JavaScript really gets to grow out
of that
some ways better than others a lot of
times people have tried to come in and
change the language into something else
that's true with flash or GWT or
CoffeeScript Dart these languages that
try to usurp JavaScript as the language
of the web and change it into something
else that it's clearly not they are all
failures they're still around in a lot
of way but their failure failures and
that they don't really have a say
get market share not in the way the
JavaScript does and they never will and
the reason is they didn't bet on
JavaScript they instead tried to change
it into something else they didn't
embrace it we're kind of going through
this again potentially with webassembly
it's not trying to be a replacement for
JavaScript but will it be time will tell
I guess on that there's a lot of really
cool stuff that you can do and I'm
really excited for what's coming down
with webassembly but from their own
website it talks about it being a
compliment to JavaScript where you can
do the computationally intensive stuff
in web assembly in a language that
transpose to web assembly and then hand
that off to JavaScript and work with it
like that they also have this
interesting quote that JavaScript has an
incredible amount of momentum and will
remain the single privileged dynamic
language of the web and that's true
but it makes me wonder if their
intentions are to to bring forth another
competitor that's not a dynamic language
so there's a lot of benefits to both
static and dynamic dynamically typed
languages javascript obviously is a
dynamically typed language and that
means that it's very flexible it's less
verbose there's not as much syntax or
ceremony that we have to do to get
things done and it's more tolerant to
change because it does a lot of type
coercion which is not necessarily a good
thing but it's something that a lot of
our code might do from time to time it
also relies less on semantics and it's
easier to test because we don't have
these nominal types that we have to meet
before we can mock things out for
example and it does provide us with a
console and a Ruppel statically typed
languages do provide a lot of benefits
as well though they will bubble the
errors up to the top earlier we don't
have to run our code or run our code in
a specific way to see the error if there
is a syntax error or a logic error the
compiler can usually catch those we get
better in code documentation through
things like type definitions and
interfaces and the compiler is a big a
big advantage in that it allows for a
disconnect between the language you're
writing and the the code that's running
and in there they can optimize the
performance and runtime efficiency of
the application
and overall it can provide a better
design time experience over time because
you get a lot of benefits in tooling
that you don't really get with dynamic
languages so why I have there been all
of these attempts to replace
JavaScript's role in on the web well
it's because JavaScript like we
mentioned it's not an application or a
language that was built to handle the
responsibilities that it has and the
responsibilities that it has are just
too important now because the web is
just huge and JavaScript projects are
changing as well so we are continuing on
with the language it's a great language
it's had a lot of changes that I'll get
to more recently but the way that it was
designed it wasn't really an set up to
handle these tasks but jeaious projects
they do share a lot of similar
characteristics as we use them more and
more and create them the sizes of
JavaScript projects are growing
exponentially they're getting bigger and
bigger and the amount of time that they
survive is getting longer and longer so
they survived several iterations with
different frameworks different different
developers that's a lifetime of the
project so we might have several
developers coming and going on the
project and they're getting really
complex to where you don't have just a
single person that understands every
intricacy of the application you have
several people and then they may come
and go over time so these these
characteristics do introduce some
bottlenecks to understanding the code
and this leads to some increased risks
as we try and change and refactor the
code and in dynamic languages this can
be a little difficult to to work with
and JavaScript just wasn't designed for
this so over the years we have worked
out ways to mitigate this risk that's
imposed by and not just in JavaScript
but in several languages but we really
try and follow key practices like
encapsulation reuse module is a module
organization error detection code style
and annotation and we've done that
through frameworks that have come out so
the language itself doesn't provide us
with a whole lot or it hasn't in the
past so we had to fill that in and
that's where frameworks like dojo
originally filled in a lot of missing
functionality with things like
Jules and promises and things like that
and then jQuery really redefined the way
that we enter we interact with the Dom
requirejs a whole module framework and
then component libraries like backbone
and angular really helped you define
that so this has all been in userland
where we've been innovating in
JavaScript to make up for the
shortcomings in the language but of
course this is 2018 and I'm talking
about JavaScript from from years ago
2018 javascript is much much better and
much much better equipped to handle a
lot of the responsibilities that it has
and that's because it has changed in a
lot of ways we've had several new
features to the language to make it has
better syntactic sugar so that we can be
more expressive in our code and adding
new features that we need to do things
like asynchronous code in a more
readable way a more human readable way
and introducing our own module syntax
and so these things combined with newer
features and tools things like NPM NPM
being the the package manager for
JavaScript meaning the package manager
for the web really allows us to fulfill
the encapsulation reuse and modular
modular ization risk mitigators that are
defined here others include static
analysis tools like es lint for advanced
error detection earlier with with
javascript wherever we can we want to
get that feedback back to the developer
as fast as possible we also introduced a
compile step with babel now because we
want to run tomorrow's JavaScript today
and the only way to do that is to
transpile back to a link to a version of
javascript that can run and then
advanced testing frameworks javascript
has really adopted a a community of
testing and so that has really advanced
the tooling around that as well and that
really helps to get error messages back
to developers quickly and then code
style we've we've kind of standardized
quite a bit on the language itself
providing better syntactic sugar for us
to be more expressive in the ways we
want to do things that's things like D
structuring arrow functions rest and
spread and default values we don't
have to have some obscure syntax to do
that now our code is much more readable
as a result but then beyond that whether
we have spaces or tabs or single or
double quotes or any of that we can kind
of watch all of that away with a
prettier config which is really great so
we can rewrite the code we can write the
code any way we want and then rewrite it
to the way that everyone agrees on but
the big missing thing is annotation and
we can provide annotations in JavaScript
by annotating our code with comments
like J's comments or or other things but
if we really want to take advantage of
any real enforceable annotations we need
to switch to something like flow or
typescript and so ask code these code
bases are getting bigger it's getting
really difficult to rely on unit tests
alone for any kind of large refactoring
efforts and as this quote points out
just relying on a test suite to do any
kind of large refactoring it's a huge
coefficient of friction on actually
doing that because you don't really want
to break the entire application in
subtle ways that you may not realize and
that your tests may not be catching and
so unit tests really aren't cut out for
that I'm not saying that the types
should replace unit tests but they are a
good complement to that and so that's
where I start talking about typescript
now so typescript was created in
Microsoft by Andrew Salzburg who created
c-sharp and turbo Pascal and Delfy and
it was released publicly in 2012 and it
adds type annotations interfaces and
generics and more to the language so
it's it's really a layer on top of
JavaScript that adds all of this to give
us these statically typed advantages in
our dynamic JavaScript language it's
very active community version 3 was just
released and it's a strict superset of
JavaScript and I think that that's
probably the biggest take away with it
is it's not a language like CoffeeScript
or Dart that's trying to change
javascript into something else it's
fully embracing JavaScript and then
extending it with types on top of it and
so it's not changing that in any way and
as long as that is one of its core
design goals
I'm a fan of that but the types are
really the least interesting part of
JavaScript of typescript it's really
what they enable so bringing back that
slide that I had the benefits of dynamic
and Static languages we really get a lot
of the static side over with Java so
with all of the benefits of JavaScript
as well we get a compile step so we get
earlier detection of mistakes in real
time we also get that with the language
service we get better built in
documentation because we can annotate
our code with types so that we know
exactly what method signatures look like
and we can't really call methods in an
incorrect way like we can in JavaScript
and we also get a better design time
developer experience through tooling so
we get a lot of benefits through the the
language server that it provides and so
with that we now have this ability to
easily refactor our code we get
intellisense so we can have Auto
completion that makes sense and that is
accurate and we get a continuous
feedback loop through that that language
service that will give us back
information about the code that we're
running and how how we can use it and
maybe what's wrong with it as we're
typing it so the best part of all of
this is the the best part of typescript
I think is that you really don't have to
switch to typescript to reap some
benefits from it you can add in this
comment this at TS check to your
javascript file and anything that
javascript are the type the type of
language service can infer about your
code it will warn you about so it will
let you know if there are any problems
in your code that you may that may be
subtle enough that you're not seeing
them all without changing anything
except adding a single comment to the
page or you can add a J's config dot
JSON to your project and Visual Studio
code embraces this and uses that on all
of your JavaScript so you get that
automatically but you can get it in any
any editor as well so I've got an
example some example code here that is
just a JavaScript file that has two
methods on it a add method and a to
relative date method and we can just add
in the TS check call a TS check comment
at the top and when we do that
it's not really going to do anything yet
because there's nothing really wrong and
that's because the way that we have it
set up I'm telling it not to worry about
implicit any's so if I disable that now
it will warn me if it doesn't really
know what a value is it's not just going
to implicitly assume that these
arguments are any instead I need to tell
it what they are and I can do that
through J s comments so now I can use
these these comments and I get feedback
from the compiler whether things are
right or wrong so here I immediately can
see that because I told it I pass in two
numbers when I actually called it I was
passing in a string it warned me about
that now in here if I change that and
say the J's comment is this argument is
a date well date doesn't have a replace
method on it so it's giving me a warning
about that but if I change it to a
string then everything is good I can
also if I don't want to use J s comments
I can just give JavaScript away or the
typescript language service a way to
infer about my code what the value
should be and I did that through adding
a default argument to it which is just
an empty string implying that the iso
string argument is going to be a string
it's the JavaScript or typescript just
immediately lets me see that and get
feedback without even having to change
over to JavaScript there are two types
script the next best bar next best part
is that JavaScript and typescript can
co-exist together in the same project so
if you decide that you want to rewrite
over to a statically typed language like
JavaScript or like Ted script you don't
have to do it all at once you can
incrementally do it slowly in any way
that you like you can change one file or
you can change all new files going
forward or you can slowly convert
everything over time and that is a huge
that lessens the barrier to adoption of
typescript which is really great so in
this code I have a javascript file
called article service and I'm just
running my build step to show that it's
all green and then I'm going to go in
and rename the file to TS and
immediately the build will fail and I
will get a few errors because again it
doesn't know what API key is so I can go
ahead and type that and give it a string
and then the article service doesn't
have an ape
Heike on it so I have to tell it that
this class does have that kind of that
property on it and that it's a string
and then the fetch articles method has a
string that you pass into it and then I
can also do things like delete my
command J s specific code and switch
this over to the es module syntax
because the compile step will convert it
to common J's or whatever module format
I'd like now here I'm changing that over
from a string to be a new source type
which is a type that I'm creating I'm
actually creating an enum up here by
converting this object into an enum
because I don't want it to just be any
string I want it to be explicitly these
six strings one of these if it's
anything other than those six then you
should give me an error and then finally
I'm creating an interface because the
fetch article's method should return an
array of articles but I don't really
know what that looks like and so I can
express that in my code you can't really
see it on this projector but there's
comments there that are showing exactly
what values were on there and there were
those values there but now instead of
just having them in comments which
aren't enforceable I have them in an
enforceable way with this interface that
I can type check against and I can
specifically say that the fetch
article's method now will return a
promise that's going to resolve to a
article array so that's a really great
benefit and then another one is that the
the type system can be subverted so one
big benefit of dynamic languages is you
don't have to worry about the exact way
the API will look and you don't have to
code all of that up and create these
interfaces you can subvert the type
system in any way that you at any time
with these compiler checks but you can
also do it by using aliases - custom
types that you might create so in the
previous example where I was using an
article instead of defining that
interface maybe I don't know exactly
what an article will look like well I
can still take advantage of that by
aliasing article to be the any type and
then use that throughout my code and
when I want to change it over to be an
article interface I can just replace
that and import the interface from
anywhere and use that and all of my code
will line up and I'm not just littering
it with any
statements anywhere everywhere so
typescript really encourages you to
develop by exposing these interfaces
really by creating these contracts that
you adhere to and its really simple to
introduce this type checking into your
project as we've seen without really
having to go fully into typescript and
converting everything all at once you
can do as much or as little as you like
the more that you do the more advantages
that you'll get from it though
so it provides this better ergonomics
story for developers on your project
it's easier for everyone to understand
what the API sar it's easier for new
developers who come on to the project
they get the smart tooling to help them
navigate the codebase and learn it and
it makes it easier to maintain that over
time especially as you need to refactor
so I work on an open source project
called dojo which received a complete
rewrite earlier this year completely
over to typescript and specifically to
strict typescript because one main focus
is on developer experience and we think
that typescript really helps us to
deliver on that so it's a really cool
project and I encourage you to check it
out and so I'll leave you with should
you use typescript probably yes but you
can decide at which level you want to
adopt it and then slowly increment that
over time this quote from Ken wheeler
these days if you aren't typing your JS
you're driving without a seat belt on I
think that that's totally totally
realistic and I believe that and so I'll
leave you with always bet on JavaScript
or a strict superset so thank you again
I'm going to be over at the the talk
script podcast booth so come check us
out and thank you very much
you